[Musique]
les gens me traitent de la vie
si tous qu'on est astucieux mais
le plus sérieux ça a joué il a mis les
moments quand est-ce qu'il ya je ne sais
pas je te dis n'est ce pas ce qui
n'engage à rien tu t'intéresses voilà
voilà petit ou qui se sentent contre moi
au bon jour d'itunes ou oui ça va tout
va on fait tu vas voir
d'abord on dit bonjour à tous nos amis
ce que tu ne provient chossy cas c'est
normal des vies beldi cei et des bd des
beaux dessins pas des belles dessin est
beau et bout oui bon dessin à
aujourd'hui
alors t'es jamais cheikh chasse à ça
c'est une illusion d'optique et vous
allez voir pourquoi regarder très
attentivement ce dessin voyez il soigne
et dessiner ça saute aux yeux
bah je ne sais pas ce qui saute aux yeux
mais si je te pose la question suivante
tout content oui est-ce que d'après toi
ce dessin est dans un rectangle c'est à
dire que cette partie là est plus longue
que cette partie là rod orma disent
qu'il est plus long que l'arm tu me
prends pour un étourneau moi je ne sais
pas pourquoi ''evidemment suisse et vous
voyez coup trois ans je te parie chaud
que tu veux bon et bien besoin d'une
forêt tu me le pari je te parie mon nid
et battu la paire du toucan corp ou
encore battu à voir je prends une règle
vous êtes une règle tout à fait normal
qu'ils aient 20 cm voilà la règle
oui alors je vais mesurer le côté vous
voyez que cela fait vingt centimètres
c'est à dire la totalité de la distance
de la règle et si je mesure la largeur
de attendait il faut que je le fasse
avec les deux mains parce que c'est un
petit peu compliqué voilà la largeur du
dessin vous apercevez que c'est
exactement la même chose également 20 cm
c'est par vingt longs cm et 20 courts
sans qui ce sont 20 cm partout qu'on
connaissait pas tricher c'est un effet
de
dick il est exactement carrés ce dessin
c'est vraiment bizarre mais c'est comme
ça c'est carré non et bien tu pourra le
refaire et en faire d'autre avec du tout
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de possibilités
dans ce domaine vient notamment
prends-moi parle elle oui on va on va
les jouer au mode cabanon mme et amour
c'est une bonne idée à lens alors je dis
tu pourrais peut-être expliquer oui
thomas ça sera oui je vais vous rappeler
brièvement les choses à vous allez voir
un certain nombre de cartons nombre
alors sur ses cartons nous avons dessiné
différente si quand des animaux et des
objets etc et vous devrez deviner ce que
représentent tous ces cartons et 1 ce
sont des syllabes en fait pour former un
mot on utilisera les syllabes et nous
formerons avec un gros je crois que ça
n'est pas très difficile vous savez
comment ça marche j'y vais m y fait bon
c'est vrai et tu sors cinq cartes alors
je sors 5 cartons du panier tu ne sors
pas de notre capacité non attention du
panic
bon allez nous avons là est impatient je
peux que faire une petite bise
non alors voyons tout encore alors nous
sommes sentis c'était voilà ça c'est un
petit rat ça c'est quoi la haine ne et
ça allait année un élu très bien ceci ça
c'est un petit journal m comme ça j'ai
un jeu vers le haut doubs un g8
et puis alors là qu'est ce que sexualis
à nice
très bien c'est un lis mes ouailles et
c'est prêt tu as trouvé quelque chose de
lyon si le roi j'ai pas eu le temps -
alors par exemple on pourrait faire est
né lolita dire tu prends la et durant le
nez et ça fait comme une soeur et n'est
moins vrai mais ou du one time et bwin
allez petite oeuvre d'ailleurs je vous
représenterez sûrement une très très
bientôt
ah bon et heureux
je suis décidément très en forme non
seulement je vois est né mais je vois
également autre chose à voir possible
déjà oui ça veut dire que je pourrais
également avec la haye faire avec le lys
et lisse au alors l'année donc alors qu
est-ce qu ensuite ensuite tu ferais
ovale à hélices 6
or à misano en oui ça c'est très fort je
ne cherchais un poète et is céline un
décalage tu es très très forte
bravo oui c'est bien non mais faudrait
peut-être tiré deux cartons
supplémentaire là même le carton
supplémentaires un ou deux oui mais
alors la touques encore oui c'est une
île est une île et ça c'est un un bout
de de cannes à pêche voyez vous ça va
bien d'ailleurs avec lille et ça
s'appelle un sion sa lady g on a déjà eu
plusieurs choses ici alors je vois pas
où on peut le placer sociaux alors
attendez quelques of roussâtre ouvert à
tous
oui comment on peut écouter voilà j'ai
est vous salt et j'ai à le g8 oui
l'homme n'est gêné chesnais le rallye
alors là je n'ai dit que sociaux
généreux suis très fort oui bravo
j'ai n'ai ration propos formidable et
bien formidable famille je vais l'écrire
ici j'ai n'ai la ration d'eau et ben tu
sais que tu es extrêmement fort
oui c'est le mot là vous voulez que vos
cookies aux non non c'est bien alors
aisé surtout pas assez bien maintenant
c'est terminé
oui oui qui pour que tu reviens tu as
super fabrice babin pourquoi je ne
reviendrai pas madame il faut c'est vrai
alors oui pourquoi parce qu'elle figure
toi qui as ouvriers ont si y'a pas du
courrier d'état fausses ok les gars
poster rapidos qui doit tirer ces jo de
sotchi c'est très bien
nous l'avions choisi parce que vous avez
la gentillesse de nous envoyer de fort
jolies lettres ce temps nous vous
remercions elles sont superbes et en
plus vous avez tous fait des dessins
extraordinaire là encore l'homme quitte
enfants qui veulent recevoir le disque
mais oui ils sont quatre d'ailleurs
non-droit pardon ce sont trois frères
bruno nicolas et benjamin qui vient
d'arriver nous distille alors vous voyez
c'est une belle famille
ils vont recevoir le disque des quatre
amis et regardé le magnifique dessin
qu'ils ont fait alors j'y suis que tu es
belle
lipton automobile est alors moi je suis
moi je moi je suis là oui tu dribbles
moi je trouve qu'il a qu'il a fait un
joli portrait bien sarah des preuves ici
ressemble en moi en ayez tous fabry nous
y sommes tous absolument bien il a bien
mérité son discours ça c'est bien vrai
et nous afficherons ce dessin la
prochaine fois d'accord on va leur
matraque fabrice ça va être à nous oui
notre petit jeu
eh bien nous y allons j'allais voir tu
n'as pas oublié ton marqueur regarde aa
a bien fait bien attention aux fautes
d'orthographe pouces conçu un jeu je
vais essayer de faire attention
alors bon alors c'est un mot en neuf
lettres oui oui la première c1 h à
trèbes bien h 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 et après la
dernière c1 e 1 e
weir a alors voilà maintenant j'attends
tes questions alors comme tu es très
gourmand en ce moment je suppose que ça
se mange
ah oui ah oui ça se voit c'est un
dessert non alors c'est pas tout à fait
un essai fois que des fois on peut déjà
faire un dessert
attends attends attends ça c'est un hors
d'oeuvre
et si on veut tu si on peut enfin c'est
un mec quoi c'est un c'est un plat et
qui est très très appréciée qu'elle
parle de la viande
ah non c'est pas de la virade l'avion ce
n'est pas un légume ce n'est pas un
légume
ce n'est pas un fruit non non plus pas
l'esprit reste alors devine je sais pas
qui est une aide supplémentaire là la
troisième lettre 1 m à 1 m
tu vois pas là alors là tu devrais
trouver un opus manger en hors-d'oeuvre
ça peut se manger un dessert et mais bon
ça y est tu as trouvé je vois
oui je sais ce que ça ne serait pas une
omelette exactement une année oui avec
un oui bah voyons
non il n'ya pas d'achat au néon sans
relâche aux mêmes ou suez le regarde
non mais vraiment tu sais une chose
qu'un progrès ça va très très mal il ya
un an et pas 1 h
oh là là là là meurent les deux alors
hommelet 200h bon gagnant 2 h 30 à la
chapelle est des zooms simplement en
tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est que
l'omelette c'est très très facile à
faire
c'est simple on casse tout et on mélange
les fassis un message quand même plus
facile que l'orthographe c'est bah
maintenant
ne perdons pas de temps à le retrouver
bell bell aucun c'est facile à musique
vers toi
[Musique]
la fondation tanguay cent alors chez
fabrice pays cutone d'être retrouvé six
jeudi à une petite devinette musique ah
bon c'est à dire que je vais te faire
entendre un son et tu dois essayer de
trouver le nom de l'instrument qui a
fait ce sont ok bagan alors j'ai ma
petite boîte
je ne te dit rien non mais je vais
appuyer sur une touche tu es coup
j'écoute études et bein oui bon ça je
sais ce que c'est c'est un très bel
instrument c'est une trompette tient
tous les tutsis mais oui c'est une
trompette c'est un cuivre un instrument
à vent qui est très difficile d'ailleurs
et un fort bel instrument il faut
souffler dedans il faut souffler de
temps il faut souffler dedans il faut il
faut savoir jeu faut avoir des lèvres
qui pensent très fort oui et c'est assez
êtes assez amusant à jouer si c'est
difficile où leur joie musique classique
ou en jazz oui oui oui les 2 sont très
difficiles souvent des livres très très
musclé gi
dis moi il me semblait jeudi pas porter
la trompait vous avez parlé de moulins
alors madame les doors est inapte et il
est rompu du mois tant dans la mine dans
la boîte noire là que tu as sorti que ce
qu'il ya dans la petite boîte qui est à
côté de moi oui oui la lune groupe est
sain de vie alors écoute je vais sortir
la trompette et puis tu vas peut-être
appuyer encore sur ta boîte cependant il
nous allons écouter une micro trompettes
qui joue différemment autre chose alors
de toucher le fasse tout de suite à
l'évasion
alors attention de mon doigt magique
j'appuie sur la petite boîte vase et ben
on sait tous qu'il faut si c'est en
résumé ce mois fait à noël
[Musique]
c'est comme ça je vais vous montrer la
trompette la voile à regarder la bia
c'est un bel instrument difficile
vous voyez que là il ya des pistes ont
des petits boutons et non sont des
pistons ça tu vois alors on raccourcit
avec les pistons l'ensemble de la
chambre des récits et ça fait des notes
différentes il faut pincer très fort on
va essayer de tirer quelques ce n'est
pas d'où est extrait officiel
c'est fatigant mais c'est beau à baffer
les locaux qui jouent bas n'ont qu'un
petit peu allez on chante la chanson
oui on sait tous la trompette alors
j'arrive avec soin la chambre avant de
chanter et les petits copains à fait
possible allez on y va
[Musique]
invitée à célébrer un avenir meilleur
les cats a dit déjà pourquoi pas fait
d'amis des tacles à iron qui se
plaignent que la vie s'est désisté et
rzeszow fait des choses mais comme jenny
pas de mine war livre on a fait
attention les gars ça glisse ça ni ce
retard is he may be
[Musique]
aujourd'hui de vouloir devenir amis